We now know that there are no legally valid
or historically valid reasons to prevent Donald
Trump's former national security advisor,
the non indicted one John Bolton from testifying
in the Senate impeachment trial.
We suspect that there are at least a couple
of Republican votes in favor of John Bolton
testifying.
We don't yet know whether there will be 51
total votes.
Republicans are absolutely panicking that
the testimony that John Bolton might give
could quote open the floodgates according
to Republican sources who spoke to Axios yesterday.
I told you that in John Bolton's upcoming
book.
He just says, Trump personally told me withhold
the aid to Ukraine until Ukraine smears Joe
Biden publicly.
So when you hear from different, uh, Trump
attorneys speculating that there was not conditionality,
that there was not pressure or whatever, and
that they have no firsthand witnesses saying
otherwise, John Bolton would be such a firsthand
witness.
He would say, presumably if he tells the same
story that he tells in his book, a boy Trump
came to me and said, uh, hold the aid until
we get these, uh, investigation announcements.
Republicans have said endlessly, they want
firsthand sources, but they are working to
block a firsthand source like John Bolton.
So first and foremost is the question of whether
four Republican senators will vote to bring
Bolton into testify.
We dealt with that in the last segment.
Then there is part two of this Axios is reporting
that Republican sources tell them party leaders
and the white house are going to try to resist
witnesses altogether, including Bolton because
as one aid put it quote, there is a sense
in the Senate that if one witness is allowed,
the floodgates are open.
If Bolton says stuff that implicates, say,
Mick Mulvaney or Mike Pompeo, then calls for
them to testify will intensify as they should.
That is exactly right.
What arguments will Republicans make against
the testimony of Bolton when it comes up?
There's going to be a few things.
One, we already heard, I played a clip earlier
of Senator John Barrasso.
They will say, you know, we're, we're doing
a lot here.
We've got 24 hours on one side, 24 hours from
the other side, 16 hours of questions.
We'll decide later.
Do we really need to hear more stuff in general,
making the argument that just looking at the
clock like just the number of hours that they've,
they've done this would suggest they don't
need to hear from witnesses.
That's a fact.
Free assessment.
They will argue that what Bolton has to say
won't change the primary facts.
Now of course that's not true.
John Bolton would be a firsthand witnesses
witness who would be able to testify personally.
Trump told me withhold the aide until they
announced the investigations.
They will say the aid which was paused, not
withheld, was ultimately released and nobody
ended up publicly smearing Joe Biden.
Now of course that happened because they got
caught and they scrambled to clean it up,
but Republicans will still use that as an
argument.
They will say the Ukrainian president has
said there was no pressure on him to announce
these investigations and that the phone call
didn't mention a specific quid pro quo.
So we don't need to hear from John Bolton.
Of course, John Bolton would still be a firsthand
witness who could tell us exactly what Trump
said, but that also ignores how politics works,
right?
These things aren't made explicit and phone
calls between the CEOs or the presidents.
It is all discussed and pushed behind the
scenes by people like Rudy, Giuliani and others.
Now, of course, every single one of those
talking points is easily debunked bubble and
it runs directly counter to the Republican
complaints about we run.
We want firsthand witnesses and we don't have
them, but they are still going to make the
strongest case possible to prevent Bolton
from testifying because they know it would
be a disaster.
So let's hear from everybody under oath.
Let's hear from everybody in public and then
let's see whether the impending Republican
acquittal makes sense based on the fact the
degree of obstruction that is taking place
when it comes to the impeachment trial is
becoming a bigger and bigger story.
I got emails yesterday from a few of you saying,
why won't Donald Trump testify?
Shouldn't Donald Trump have to testify in
his own impeachment trial?
No, he shouldn't have to.
That's not the law.
Any good lawyer would probably prevent their
client from testifying in equivalent circumstances,
but does anybody think Donald Trump could
handle under oath testimony?
Donald Trump would be uncontrollably lying
within minutes, if not seconds, and would
perjure himself.
He would likely have a real additional wrongdoing
that he's not even being impeached for.
Hillary can handle it.
Remember she testified how many hours was
it dozens of hours for the Bengazi fiasco?
Trump would implode in seconds, and that may
actually be an interesting narrative to try
to go Donald Trump into testifying.
Remind him, Hillary did it.
Hillary did it.
Now the circumstances are completely different,
but this is Trump.
We're talking about.
He wants to be bigger and stronger and more
powerful and braver than Hillary.
Maybe you could actually get them to demand
that his lawyers let them testify.
Unlikely.
Final note, I don't think that if Bolton testifies,
Republicans vote to impeach.
Okay.
I've said this before.
I believe if Bolton testifies, Republicans
still vote to acquit, but it will be that
much more embarrassing and obvious that from
the get go acquittal was a foregone conclusion.
Acquittal was what they plan to do from the
beginning.
They will still acquit Donald Trump, but the
Bolton testimony could stick in people's minds.
John Bolton publicly testifying and saying,
Donald Trump personally told me, withhold
the aid to Ukraine until they announced the
investigations.
It could influence the November election.
It might help to get Donald Trump out if and
when we go out to vote in nine months.
That's why it's important, not because it
will get Republicans to vote to convict the
guy.
They're not going to do that.
Make sure you're following the David Pakman
show on Instagram at David Pakman show.
Follow me at David dot Pacman.
I posted one of the ugliest pate mails I've
ever received this morning on my Instagram
page at David dot pack.
Check it out.
Take a quick break
and a lot more to
this stuff to
death